[Music]
communication not only helps us learn
and understand
but it helps us to connect and to feel a
sense of belonging
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
[Music]
today I look forward to speaking with
Jeffrey Cohen Jeff holds many
appointments at Stanford he is a
professor of organizational studies in
education and business at The Graduate
School of Education he's a professor of
psychology and a lecturer in management
Jeff's research focuses on applying
research-based interventions to pressing
social problems he recently released a
new book called belonging the science of
creating Connection in bridging divides
welcome Jeff thanks for being here I am
really excited for our conversation
thank you Matt for having me so let's go
ahead and get started can you define
what you mean by belonging well it's a
great question I could go on at length
but let me give a quick answer belonging
is the sense of being included and
accepted by a larger group it's that
feeling we get when we feel like we're
part of a larger whole that accepts us
for who we are in the ideal state so
it's both a a state and a process a noun
and a verb and it seems like in both of
those both the noun and verb version
that there are lots of benefits that it
confers on us what are some of those how
does belonging help us well as human
beings we are fundamentally social
creatures and we've evolved to kind of
have a social orientation because we
need each other to survive and to thrive
otherwise we're just highly vulnerable
to predation and disease out there in
the wild and so the human species has
evolved to go through life together and
that's actually what the the word
belonging means to go together and
there's all kinds of benefits to joining
together right we can solve common
problems together we can do together
what as individuals we could only
imagine doing we're capable great
projects and products but also in
addition down to our very biology We
crave connection when we don't have it
when we feel disconnected from the rest
of humanity this what's called a state
of of loneliness it actually does
biological damage it's one of the most
toxic environmental social environmental
factors out there to to not have that
sense of connection with other people
does great biological damage and seems
to be one of the major contributors to
disease and mortality and early death so
I would say that the the benefits to
belonging are that we can together do
more than we can as individuals but also
biologically psychologically that sense
of connection is so woven into our DNA
that if we don't have it we suffer
belonging and feeling connected sound
like they're absolutely critical to to
just being human and it sounds like from
a benefit side there are productivity
benefits but they're also psychological
relational benefits and certainly
there are biological challenges if
you're lonely and not connected or
feeling a sense of belonging and I and I
can only imagine that there are lots of
mental consequences it strikes me that
belonging can come in two different
varieties at least there there's a big b
belonging where we feel connected to
others at a deep emotional and
fundamental way as we do with our
lifelong friends and family but also a
little B belonging where we feel
Connection in a more superficial like
way uh for example followers we have on
social media that we've never met or
someone who shares a birthday with us or
even somebody who likes the same sports
teams as we do there's a little B
belonging help us in the same way as Big
B belonging does Big B belonging is
better
I like the alliteration Big B belonging
is better you know one of in the Harvard
study for example one of the big
predictors of longevity or Quality
Social connections Quality Social
relationships it's as important I think
it's about the the effect size is about
twice the effect size of having a
healthy diet or exercising having good
social connections that sense of being
accepted for who you are that kind of
authentic sense of connection that is I
think very hard to get online through
these very superficial small B
connections that we have online that
that sense of being accepted for who we
are that authentic connection is really
really important but also that sense of
being of service to others being someone
who matters who's important to other
people to give is to create love those
deep connections are so good for our
health and well-being so much so that
even if you do these little studies my
friend Sonia libermersky and Steve Cole
and Barb Fredrickson have done these
little studies where they just randomly
assign people to create these more deep
deeper meaningful connections by doing
acts of kindness throughout a couple
weeks so they instruct people to either
you know do something good for yourself
that you enjoy or do something that's
helpful to other people and act of
kindness then they look at biological
markers of inflammation and they find
that inflammation is much lower among
those people who engage in these acts of
kindness of service to others that's not
the kind of thing we get online I mean
I'm not denying that that's possible and
I'm not denying that people who have
faced a lot of exclusion and who can't
find their Niche can find some sense of
Home online that definitely happens but
I think too often the social media kind
of relationships that we have are not
high quality they're voyeuristic often
and performative often and that does
doesn't have the same kinds of benefits
for well-being and personal strength so
it sounds to me that that stockpiling
followers and friends online might not
be the best strategy having a few close
really intimate friends if you will is
important you've already begun to to
shed some light into this Jeff and I'd
like to push you a little bit more but
what are some strategies and tactics we
can use to build and enhance our sense
of belonging and our personal
relationships and and what role does
communication play in in that I've
already mentioned one of them and that
is giving giving being of service is one
way to create a powerful sense of
connection
there's research for instance on
teenagers adolescents and what benefits
their their sense of connection and
helps their health and well-being and
one answer turns out to be volunteerism
getting involved in volunteer activities
where you're serving some pro-social
Services
pro-social cause bigger than yourself
that is very beneficial that's one
strategy is to engage in activities in
which you are giving to others and being
of service to others and it's not
something that I think comes naturally
to us today in our era we are often
committing these sort of what are known
as affective forecasting errors what we
think is good for for us in our
connections isn't necessarily actually
good for us in our connections we think
that often pursuing our own status and
self-interest will bring us health and
happiness and it turns out that that's
not nearly as impactful as doing good
for others in terms of communication I
think communication styles are are
really important for maintaining our
relationships being able to communicate
in a in an effective way such that we
not only
express our personal interests and
preferences and desires but are
respectful of others that that's so
important and just to give one example I
know that sounds like a platitude in the
abstract but just to give one example
one of my former students Michael
schwabe did a did a great study looking
at the political divide and he wanted to
make that go smoother such that liberals
and conservatives could talk better with
each other more respectfully
and he found that most of the time that
didn't go well people were kind of
resistant to the points of view of the
other party but he found that one little
communication strategy had a big effect
and that was to use two words before you
express your point of view or your
position on a policy and those two words
were I think
I think this person is better this is
from my point of view this is my
position and he found that just using
these sort of linguistic markers that
create a sort of subjective space for
someone else's point of view that say
Hey this is a sort of common space where
we're trying to figure out together
the best way to look at this issue that
that actually opened up the other side
to learning more about people's own
position made the other side less likely
to denigrate the person speaking and
just create a more curiosity and Common
Ground so that's just one example of how
our communication can foster these kinds
of connections even in difficult
conversations I really like this notion
of being in service of others doing
volunteering as a way to to help you
feel connected I love Linguistics and
and I just using I think makes you sound
less definitive and it makes you sound
more open to other points of view and so
I I appreciate that as as good advice
and and I think I should employ that
more frequently
so how can we as colleagues and managers
create more inclusive and welcoming
communities to Foster belonging I
believe you have a term you call
situation crafting and how would that
play into this
situation crafting refers to the art and
the science of creating situations that
are conducive to sense of belonging and
that bring out people's personal and
Collective best and it's based on this
Insight from social psychology about the
power of situations
so oftentimes when we're looking out
there in the world trying to figure out
the causes of behavior we blame people
we overestimate the importance of things
like ability and character these sort of
internal traits and we underestimate the
importance of the situation like people
may have some circumstance that we don't
know about that's affecting how they're
dealing a lot of times students for
instance act out in class because
they're feeling uncertain about their
belonging in school I'm sorry about how
they're seen and it's not so much that
they are troublemakers but rather the
situation of school creates this feeling
of alienation in them that
leads them to behave in these ways that
are that are just not not healthy for
themselves and and for the and for the
school so by changing the way we act
what we say what we do we can change
situations for the better often
sometimes even in profound ways for
instance Greg Walton and I did a little
study where we were looking at how to
create more belonging among
students college students making the
transition into college which is often a
time of huge belonging uncertainty where
people are uncertain about whether they
belong and whether they can find a home
and all we did I'm going to sort of
simplify is to share with those students
the stories of senior students at their
school and these stories convey to them
you know I had a lot of trouble
adjusting to college myself and over
time things got better and what we found
that was that over the course of two
years that that little
experience
close the achievement gap between
students of color and their white peers
by half students of color are often the
ones who are experiencing stronger
belonging uncertainty in college you
also brought up as a great point of
where communication comes in helping
people craft stories that they can then
share with others is is important and
and creating an environment where it's
okay to share vulnerability can help as
well and I can imagine organizations
could set up opportunities to to get
together like affiliation groups Etc to
invite people to come connect so if
there's a group of people at work who
like to exercise they could go for a run
together or if there are people
interested in learning about a new topic
as managers and colleagues we can invite
people in to feel that sense of
belonging is that a reasonable thing to
do I think so and I think our our
theories of what makes people happy
don't often include that and our
theories of what makes workers and
employees productive often don't include
those little opportunities for
seemingly meaningless connection but
it's not really meaningless I mean I
would often find as a young Professor
that I could feel intense belonging
uncertainty when I was starting out I
was I really felt you know with all the
Silverbacks there at the University of
that at the time that I wasn't sure if I
belonged and then yet I'd be going to
the copy room and bump into a student in
my classroom we'd have a little
conversation about the class or a
reading and suddenly felt feel better I
feel better I'd even feel more energized
and I think that's what these little
what social psychologists call passive
contacts do you meet at the water cooler
when you join a little Club to do
something together like exercise or
enjoy a hobby together these these
things that we don't really have
theories good theories for explaining
why they make people healthier why they
make people more productive they
actually really do matter so I I think
you're absolutely right and I think
managers and leaders can create those
opportunities for connection and and can
also just through inquiring about
people's interests and values asking
good questions I just want to get to
know you better also create that thank
you for that I think everybody can tick
off that list of things they can do at
work as managers as colleagues to really
help people
I I want to flip the coin a little bit
here when when Robert cialdini was a
guest we talked about ways people can
use our deep connections with others and
our sense of belonging and need to
belong as a way to manipulate or to
influence or persuade us which leads me
to wonder is is there a dark side to
belonging that we should be concerned
about you know this issue comes up a lot
belonging
is a psychological need we have a need
to belong
which can be
channeled into either good outcomes or
bad and I think too often it's
exploitative for bad outcomes that need
to belong if we're not getting it if
we're not fulfilling our need to belong
through work or through mainstream
institutions or through our family we
become vulnerable to the appeals of hate
groups extremist groups we become
vulnerable to the views of our political
tribes just conforming to them out of a
need to belong I think what this means
is that if we exist in a society where
people aren't getting those sort of
constructive channels for belonging at
work at home through their family and
their schools then they become
vulnerable to these these other much
more destructive forces and that's a big
problem before we started the podcast we
talked about we played the name game
since we had some overlap at Stanford
and I studied with Phil zimbardo and he
had a class on the psychology of mind
control and one aspect of that was
around Cults and how Cults prey on
people who feel disconnected and and
they provide opportunities for
connection and when and I started
teaching persuasion and influence on my
own years later I started a cult in my
class to demonstrate this and we started
the Church of chocolate Obsession Coco
and I was brother carob we read from the
holy truffle I mean it was this whole
thing but the point was to show to
students how very quickly in the matter
of a 20-minute class activity we were
able to create a sense of belonging to
something that was completely ludicrous
Hershey kisses and Godiva bars but the
point is that sense of belonging is
strong and can be manipulated and and I
think you highlighted the downside
potentially of it yeah it's strong can
be manipulated so Jeff before we end I'd
like to ask you the same three questions
I ask everybody who joins me are you up
for that yes excellent here we go
question one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be listen to people's hearts not kids
okay listen to their hearts not heads so
talk to me about listening to people's
hearts what does that mean and what does
that look like oftentimes when we get in
these conflicts with people who engage
in behavior that we find objectionable
the underlying causes are emotional
issues there are emotional issues and
what people are saying their points of
view their opinions don't you know they
they're there but they're often
reflections of these underlying
emotional issues and concerns such as
not quite feeling like one belongs and
some of the examples that I gave to you
earlier such as a student in school who
acts out that might seem like that might
seem like the kid just has really bad
attitudes these are beliefs about how
they should be in school something in
their head but actually it's something
in their heart they're not quite feeling
like they fit in in school and so a good
teacher good educator who listens to
that and understands that you know just
like me I can just like myself I can act
in
in regrettable ways but I'm not quite
feeling at home and so that's what I
think listening to people's hearts means
I really like the way you phrase that I
mean it's it's it's operationalized
empathy right it's it's it's really
tuning in to to what you're seeing and
experiencing not just what you're
hearing so thank you
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
Marshall Rosenberg
tell me more psychologist who passed
away and he was actually the originator
of that quote which I distilled down to
seven words he was like a Jedi master
of listening and he would say he would
have these very difficult conversations
with people or why not only with
different political beliefs but people
who are highly prejudiced bigots and you
just try to talk to them and listen and
people are like well how could you do
this he's like you know I have just
learned that I really
can maintain my love for people and
enjoy life a lot better if I listen to
what's in their hearts not so much not
pay so much attention to what's in their
heads so he has this technique of
non-violent Communication in which you
begin if you have some problem with
someone you begin with an emotion you
know I feel
disrespected I feel upset I feel angry
when when you do this when for instance
you
leave the dishes in the sink and you
don't clean up F and you don't clean
them up because I have a high need
psychological need to be respected too
often we don't begin with our emotions
instead we just try to control the other
person his method of non-violent
communication is something that really
stuck with me
in which you just begin with what you're
feeling and you explain how what you're
feeling derives from the psychological
need and it's then that you make an ask
for a change in Behavior so he's one
person that really stuck with me as a
master communicator and listener and
that's exactly what I was going to point
out I asked the question about a
communicator and you went to somebody
who who starts communication by
listening and that's often forgotten
right we often think about the words
people speak or write or sing and in
fact listening is is a super powerful if
not more powerful way to communicate at
first let me ask you question number
three
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
as you said listening
doing what social psychologists call
prospective getting which is asking good
questions
and listening to the answers
and then communicating your point of
view respectfully using some of these
linguistic markers that indicate this is
my first person point of view so I think
that those three ingredients are really
crucial
listening to the other person listening
to what's in the heart not so much
what's in the head asking questions that
dig a little bit deeper so that you get
people's perspective rather than assume
it and then after that's done providing
your point of view in this sort of
respectful way that makes it clear that
this is your first person point of view
I really find that process helpful
listen
inquire and then share from your own
perspective your response and taken
together that is a good
recipe and series of steps that we could
all benefit from
so Jeff this has been a fantastic
conversation uh I this notion of
connecting in in belonging are critical
communication plays a central role in
that and your best practices and
specific references to research and ways
that we can work to Foster belonging and
connection are really important thank
you for your time and thank you for your
advice thank you Matt for a wonderful
conversation
you've been listening to another episode
of think fast talk smart the podcast a
production of Stanford Graduate School
of Business this podcast was produced by
Jenny Luna Kevin Patel and me Matt
Abrahams with special thanks to Podium
podcast company
to find more episodes visit our website
at
gsb.stanford.edu or find us wherever you
get your podcasts including YouTube for
more business related content follow the
business school on social media at
Stanford GSB you can also find the
podcast and follow us on LinkedIn and
Instagram
foreign